hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion so i've just had covered so if my
voice sounds a bit funny that's why
anyway on to the video
over many decades plastic waste has
become a major problem not just for the
environment but to us as humans as well
in fact recently plastic has been
detected in human organs and this year
for the first time it's been detected in
human blood
many are sleeping on the issue but maybe
something can be done
you are watching cold fusion tv
in 2016 japanese scientists were sifting
through the debris of a plastic bottle
recycling plant they were in search of a
bacterium that could degrade plastic
the type of plastic that the scientists
were looking for was polyethylene
pteraphophthalate or p-e-t for short
this type of plastic accounts for 12 of
all global solid waste
if you've ever used a water bottle
that's p-e-t it's found in a lot of
other modern products including clothing
and packaging estimates say about 50
million tonnes are produced every year
globally by 2025 this could be 100
million tons as the demand for the
material grows so does the mountain of
plastic waste in landfills as pet-based
products are notoriously difficult to
recycle
the goal of the japanese scientist trash
hunt was to find a bacterium that could
use pet as its energy source
after bringing plastic samples back to a
lab what they found was ideonella
cycaensis a bacteria that amazingly eats
plastic and converts it to carbon
dioxide from here the team discovered
that the organism has two enzymes that
break down the plastic into basic
components we'll talk about the
importance of the enzyme soon
so in short the bacteria completely
digested the plastic and used it to
power its
what's left is carbon dioxide and the
monomers usually ethyl glycol and
pterophalic acid these components can
make new plastic
[Music]
plastics like pet are made from little
chemicals joined in a chain
the enzyme unlinks that chain and then
you get a bunch of components you can
then use these components and recycle
them into another chain
so basically this enzyme could be used
in the recycling process without any
extra energy input
well you might be thinking that's great
why haven't we used this everywhere
well there's one problem
in the real world the bacteria and even
the isolated enzymes weren't very
practical it did the job but it was very
fussy about it
if the temperature was too low or too
high or the ph wasn't just right it
wouldn't work effectively there had to
be a way to improve this
knowing that an enzyme consists of amino
acids linked together to form proteins
if these amino acids could be tweaked
perhaps the enzyme would perform better
but how could this be done
enter ai
[Music]
in may of 2022 a team from the
university of texas at austin in the
united states used a neural network to
engineer and improve the performance and
stability of the plastic destroying
enzyme
a machine learning algorithm was in
charge of modifying the amino acids in
the
enzyme the neural network called mute
compute studied a diverse range of 19
000 proteins of a similar size
it was to learn the patterns of what
makes a protein stable
according to hal alpa who was the
principal investigator of the study
amino acids that fit well within the
protein are the key to stability
an amino acid that isn't a good fit may
be a source of instability
when this happens the performance of the
enzyme falls off
when the algorithm saw that an amino
acid might not fit well it suggested a
different amino acid in its place
for each of the 290 amino acids the
program checks to see if it fits well
within its immediate structural
environment compared to other proteins
within its knowledge base
this means that it can balance the
evolutionary trade-off between activity
and stability which now when i think
about it is insane
we're observing nature and then hacking
it to do our bidding
out of the millions and millions of
combinations the ai suggested three
amino acid substitutions
the team decided to go with the ai's
design the result was quote highly
highly active especially at lower
temperatures compared to anything else
that's out there
the ai-designed enzyme broke down an
entire plastic tray within 48 hours
it breaks down plastic at over twice the
speed and at lower temperatures compared
to the next best engineered enzyme they
demonstrated that untreated consumer pet
plastics could almost completely be
degraded in one week they tested 51
different products including whole
plastic containers and bottles they were
also able to make new recycled plastic
objects that consumed much less energy
than traditionally would be required the
team managed to retrieve 94.9 percent of
the raw materials needed to make new
plastic
[Music]
since the plastic degrading is being
done by an enzyme and not the whole
bacteria it has the added benefit of not
being able to reproduce uncontrollably
other experts in the field are impressed
sarah cacadilus he studies the plastics
bioeconomy at the imperial college of
london in the uk comet quote it's a
drastic improvement compared to other
enzymes that have been developed so far
the great advantage of enzymes is that
they can be much more specific than
chemical catalysts it could be easier in
theory to degrade much more diverse
waste using enzymes what i really liked
about the study is the fact that they
took it outside the lab to some extent
she's referring to trying the enzyme on
real plastic products bought at a local
supermarket instead of a lab
buy-in wu from the chinese academy of
science states quote this study proved
the machine learning method is useful in
enzyme engineering
he goes on to state that the ai managed
to uncover certain modifications that
were ignored by other methods
the texas team is continuing to
investigate the practical aspects of
enzyme recycling as well as expanding
the range of materials
so what are some drawbacks it should be
noted that the enzyme's optimal working
temperature is 50 degrees celsius which
is too high to work in ambient
conditions
but perhaps with better neural networks
we could take this optimal operating
temperature down to ambient room
temperature
so in conclusion there are still massive
amounts of work to be done to solve the
plastic waste problem but this is the
start really it is actually early days
seeing that the enzyme itself was only
found in 2016 but this latest news about
ai making it much more practical i think
is a bright spot to watch
it's interesting because whenever i talk
about ai there's a small subset of
viewers that keep asking why can't ai do
useful things to them my other episodes
about ai making music art
writing and having conversations was
entirely useless
but i think a super efficient enzyme
designed by ai for the sole purpose of
destroying plastic is something that
most people could appreciate as we've
already started to see on this channel
the ai cycle of improvement is
exponential so who knows what changes
could come to enzyme design in the
future
so what do you guys think feel free to
discuss here or on the cold fusion
discord
if you think more people should know
about this feel free to pass this
episode along
so for some housekeeping i've been
nominated for an award so i'll be
traveling to amsterdam soon i'll try my
best but if there's a gap in uploads
this is why also check out the latest
episode of the through the web podcast
that i co-host we discuss some updates
on the lunar dokuan situation for those
interested anyway
anyway that's it from me
my name is digogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll see you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cold fusion
it's me thinking